guardatele bruttissimo 9 maggio corre
oggi nuovissima challege chi sopravvive
il mio bilancio è infatti da uomo che
non ha né tutti i cattivi anche dei
nuovi cattivi che non conoscete non
abbiamo ancora affrontato chi
sopravviverà per piste petru meritano in
gara e alla fine si descrive tc qual è
il cattivo che vi è piaciuto più di
tutti
vi eccoci qua io in vita le allora come
funziona questo come funzioni sono dei
cattivi che appaiono ogni tanto noi ora
siamo qua nella nostra base e nella
nostra postazione ma dobbiamo scendere e
condito la siamo qua sotto e cassotta
paiono dei cattivi esatte riesce a
sopravvivere in cinquanta o sessanta
secondi al cattivo sei sopravvissuto ed
apparirà un altro cattivo 40 ma ogni
volta il cattivo è un personaggio
diverso famoso tra i più cattivi in
questo caso non so chi sia
credo sia vostra among us il personaggio
cardine among us no quello è il
giocatore
allontanati dai luglio vedere chi è che
non so chi sia il cambio ma questa volta
per andarsene mancano dieci secondi
saremmo sopravvissuti bene sono salite
nella base di qualcun altro è il salento
era seduta al tavolo ci sono dei
biscotti meglio non dirlo a vitale
perché se no arriva su dove sono
iscritti quando che avvicina se stessimo
parlando
pronto che se qualcuno ha stonato
uscendo dalla base p3 semmai pighi of
the call all'ufficio rodano piccolo giù
del giorno non avendo nella bat è quella
di fatta di legno che se lo vedo da qui
[Musica]
si sta salendo non so se sarai tu
mi ha preso a a
10 perché io sono stata presa mentre un
vitale no io mi sto avvicinando a picchi
invece mancava e ti stai avvicinando 26
rapisce lo picchia
scappando voglio salire qui in 10 dove
vai qui sulle scale bella questa base ma
se mi sfiorare anch'io tutte le basse
come ora preso quando me tanto pd è
laggiù che sta facendo una strage di
quegli altri che arrivò anch'io vorrei
sapere come hanno fatto gli altri
giocatori e trasformarsi
microcar se ci sono diamo stessi quel
vestito intorno sono entrata prima c'è
la cucina ha cucinato qualcosa dai
dobbiamo andare affrontare i cattivi è
un atto in mare prima gara qui dal frigo
che c'è anche una dubbia di questa
stanza stiamo saliamo c'è altro cibo la
somma guardia mi sono trasformato in
rometta ma dopo acquista una casa
sull'albero bene qua sul pulsante anche
noi ma la nostra fondiamo la sua nota
siamo tutti impostori adesso è arrivato
l'altro cattivo più cattivo c'è scritto
emily e mi sapete chi è il cattivo emily
io voglio detenute 6 investono in mano
al campo eccola io non sono stupito la
mia di cui 2 che sale ora siamo noi
inseguendo vitale ma mi ha lasciato non
lasciamo stare sempre di sì lui che
voglio capire che c'è mancato poco
bionda inquietante io sono al sicuro qui
dai media pure tu
cosa succede se proprio questi pulsanti
qui salendo nell'altra base se ne sta
andando
siamo sopravvissuti li vediamo chi è il
prossimo my skin walker ma voi lo
conoscete sicuramente poi ne conoscete
più di noi di cattivi iscriversi nei
commenti che lo skin walker non lo vedo
ancora forse invisibile che io ho
premuto questo pulsante ma non mi
trasformo più lei e mi butto l'acqua e
button e questo credo sia qui che in
acqua tratta questo è l'ultimo nascondi
brano
io soltanto allora sei dove sei ti vedo
raggiunto il carrello sopra vedi qui su
questa casetta quindi possono salire
nelle basi vengono lo vedi ciao stories
valli città osservandosi ma tra un pochi
secondi sta a casa nella vita
tutto bianco ma io non mi avvicinerei
così tanto mi sta chiamando
novo una maggio correre è appreso a due
a zero almeno sono tornata normale sono
tornata di testori sono sono più il
fiume vediamo chi sarà il prossimo mare
la maschera che maschera mettiamo io lo
sterno da quassù ma tu dove sei
o meglio che vanno altrimenti verrò
sfracellata un'altra volta vita e si
gode lo
farò se si nasconde detto horiki del
giorno lecca lecca
lasciate un mi piace per far uscire allo
scoperto vitale sono qui e guarda sotto
in tre secondi stretto
tempo scaduto
il vuoto questo punto bravi bravissimi
rispetti ecco vitale ma dov'è finito il
killer
d'altra parte io un'idea saliamo in una
base che non abbiamo esplorato questa
l'abbiamo esplorata si fa forza
sull'albero quella visiva milan dobbiamo
esplorata andiam io credo che siamo
killer arriverà in tre secondi briga
briga un'africa disinnescato suite iwork
quello di spongebob veramente vabbè una
dei cattivi macro chiamava in italiano
quindi squisita che fosse squiddy da
questa è la stessa casa dove siamo
saliti prima andava allora quando si
teneva lo stesso uomo
ok allora cucina scendiamo giù e andiamo
ad esplorare quella casa vicino alla
cascata 10 mar la cascata bordo con lui
è velocissimo anche lui lo vedi
massacrando tutti vedo tribal ovvero gli
altri ma qua non si può entrare sì
perché hanno messo ai laser io prima mi
rifugiavo là dentro e da me avrei temuto
aprile è come se fosse attraver da corri
corri prima che mi milk in vai se devi
sbrigarti sono qui vai iq
d'italia grazie per avermi aperto
allora c'è il computer
ancora un po preistorico questo computer
o sempre il sacrosanto di lei dpf
traverse fritti la tv a colori
cioè nel senso che cambia colore prima
verde poi celesti e video juliet altro
qua dentro il piccolino ma questa base
si sono insieme armature
vabbè si possono prima ora guarda
aspetta nel futuro prendo questa qui
cambiarla
san giovanni
qual è la vostra armatura preferita
proviamo le tutte perché a me non mi fa
cambiare perché tutte un fiume tumen
quindi dovevamo prendere la tpl scp
quello che sto per uno scheletro pauroso
bene io andrò da sotto l'armatura sì
l'ho visto con l'armata doveva fare
niente e andiamo da qui facciamo poi
vediamo l'ultimo che prova questa verde
a degli uomini ma che la star preferita
la mia
la pri no questa celeste bianca a tutte
le mie preferite
siamo pronti ad affrontare in sc p
abbiamo purtroppo colpirlo io
non pensa aiuto mi sono spaventato e
ritmo e gioco il vestito di d'amore
tassi sono riconosciute e diamo set con
l'armatura sono immortale e non potrà
prendere avvio tutto di te eccolo è
laggiù che rimane lì fermo molto strano
questo cammino e molto strano e
inquietante questo killer ma quanti
punti siamo i 250 a 300
quanto è brutto sentito c'è l'armatura
via che potreste mi nascondo qua dietro
all'albero comunque va piano sembra
andare più ambita che sta via via visto
giochiamo udine nei canti
è attento tutto il mondo divino è salito
sopra che ha fatto perché sisti evitando
forse ha paura di noi perché ho la super
armatura non penso forse siamo riusciti
ha avuto prove wow vediamo chi è il
prossimo tanto lo affronterò con la mia
armatura vitale ancora crew match
g g
voglio vedere come l'hanno creata poi
vediamo eccola laggiù
e piano piano è
corre tantissimo corrado bellissimo e
strafottente tutto cuore striscia perché
i gremi così piccola sembra un
personaggio leggo
aiuto ho cercato di scappare piacere
sono qui mi sta inseguendo dappertutto
voglio trovare evitabile becco tt vedono
il cian ba e ma non ti lascia non ti
lasciano in quel destro nome resi cadute
in ha veramente fatto forse sei riuscito
a farla no è con la star e vado e naro
possa essere presa
sono allontanati si sta salendo subito
perché però quasi letta io sono riuscito
a sopravvivere a gremiti rendiconto ma
io sono stato per aiutarti e ora
non ci credo 4 a 0
vediamo se trovo qualcos'altro da
prendere magari trovo un'arma da
prendere contro graham il prossimo
cattivo il clown grazer i nomi di stare
attenti ma ce lo vedo bene
eccoli la giusta cercando di entrare nei
laser vedi nord ove stata ok il look e
paura è riuscito a entrare eliminato
tutti perché qualcuno ha aperto in asta
amico ho preso le scarpe veloce invece
una barra della vita se riusciamo a
trovare un'arma ma diciamolo un pinger i
cattivi wow guardai le scarpe veloci
guardava caffè o scambiato il mio
scambiate contro i punti no vabbè è
veramente posso fare così dimmi dove
allora devi salire qua sopra
ok vado subito eccovi praticamente puoi
scambiare i punti con queste cose io ho
preso da scarpe il pd sono io o 125
punti quindi potrei prendere o le scarpe
cussino scorretta bello questo è quanto
più cosa posso che fa allora vitale poi
prende una torcia poi questo non so che
cos'è le scarpe la pozione danzando in
realtà vorrei questo qua che uno sparerà
due non abbastanza punti oppure questo
250 punti quindi ho deciso che mi
conservo il punti per prendere uno di
questi e tu che fai vuoi riprendere le
scarpe io prendo questo dovevamo come
funziona
[Musica]
bellissimo potevamo regalare punti per
prendere il cuscino con sopra
una volta lo aspetta lo posso dimettere
guarda passa
[Musica]
26 capi da un cattivo su questo titolo
forse le mini dobbiamo andare e metterla
come dragon è incattivita la trama
da chi è cattivo aspetta una sorta di
pupazzo blu gigante
siamo sopravvissuti ok ma ho capito
forse a poppi quel file foto vediamo chi
sono io provo a mettere un po di dai
dobbiamo fare la trappola un cattivo un
po dei cuscini scoreggioni qua intorno
no di nuovo quello listing
non sono stato io questa volta lo sono
stato io no peccato solo uno alla volta
sarebbe un mese io ho un'idea mettilo
qua dove si sono i laser che ci sono un
sacco di per store che schiacceranno di
sicuro eccoci qua sono tutti nascosti
qua
il cattivo nota
papa ha preso mi ha preso viale mentre
hanno preso anche mancando il killer
schiacciato anche il cuscino scorre joe
5 a 1 che io ho
175 punti aiutato 50 prendo questa
pozione danzante vediamo che cosa
succede lì dove sei sono qua sotto ho
messo le scarpe le spedisce aspetta che
arrivò e dove sono i cattivi non c'è
nessuno
tra noi da un uomo esplorato con dario
che la mappa controllo se c'è qualcosa a
è collocato se provo un pulsante posso
entrare dei prof questa è un'ottima
protezione
creativo rimane chiuso dentro e continua
a fare i punti forza in meno che
qualcuno non si chiuda dentro e mette
dentro
poi non puoi più uscire provato
entrarono un attimo e così non ti
avevano conosciuto nella tua forma
normale e rod entrare un attimo vediamo
se ti chiudo il prossimo cattivo e
sereno
dobbiamo volerlo andiamo a vederlo ce lo
troviamo questa pozione cos'è la tante
che succede ha emesso una palla da
discoteca la soprano vede e ma non va
letto ora però preoccupa
ma un po sprecato i miei punti e inutile
che si capì punti attento potrebbe
essere molto veloce ma io c'ho le mie
speedy shunsuke sono velocissime dovevo
solo arrivare a cielo già addosso e
invece il cuscino scorreggione ce l'hai
ancora incerto va bene quindi una volta
presti con i puntini si vivono lo sai
che non lo vedo sereno
no non c'è vediamo prova entrare nel
punto dei ladri bella dentro l'anno
chiudono al the grove
sicily ma se lo vedo ma geniale questa
cosa ok allora li mettiamo una scorretta
commesso la pozione danzante funziona
hai visto tu sì ma toni di daniele
cose che sono le mie spedizioni
aiuti che abbiamo fatto
allora o userà i 150 e 175
bobby ma perché ci sono menti cattivi ma
il gigante così nel cassetto tempo
guai
ok io metto e ai cinque pasti tutti è
meglio se saliamo in una base sta
facendo fuori tutti non delle tue di
michael
che possiamo provare eliminato tutti
allora c'è un file sono 50 punti messo
anche le gomme ma questa ti sei messo in
testa
come succo di tutto il bouquet conte
no no mi sono trasformato di nuovo in
pole pupazzetto colorato questo
incremento arcobaleno
che bello guarda questa aumenta la
velocità di 20 finalmente sono più
veloce attivo e caino
aiuto corri chi come la gori
perché sì soprattutto non è ma chi è
questo vengono salvati se mi chiedi
baldi ti ha preso in aria l'espressività
parli
ma come è possibile
cioè io sto andando velocissimo
[Musica]
sono qui sulle scale mi sta inseguendo
fu forse ha preso un altro nome ecco
dove sei tu non è quello che scappando
via durando si è troppo veloce e il più
difficile
comunque in realtà se tu stai al piano
di sotto per terra fai molti più punti
ottenuti nelle banche
oggi atroce di nuovo quindi siamo tifosi
a sostenere una cover nardi e fermo la
sopra non so perché se fermandoli
a perché stava inseguendo me poi io mi
sono hanno appreso qualcuno usa
bloccato è praticamente sono saltato da
quella casa lui è rimasto bloccato
limitati e bagnato
no no non ho bloccato che
finanzia come questo musichetta sotto
lenta ed evocativo e popi playtime e
quel pupazzo gigante blu
questo fa paura lo vedi
devo prendere qualcosa un'arma da
tirarli ad 89 75 punti che gli girano la
scorreggia
lista pretendo tutti sì perché è gigante
però non è velocissimo almeno vedi
nomale da io ho messo le scarpette
veloce giusta per essere sicuri io devo
riuscire a non ha l'ok ad oliveri faccio
più punti si incastrato li svagato
inquietante con questa musichetta to
aver dato le bruttissimo
attenta a non farti prendere qui all
angolo tra via scriveteci qual è il più
pauroso tra questi cattivi secondo me
questo ha vinto perché si muove così
si è incastrato ii verra posso anche
dare indietro e non tentano
non ci posso credere mi sta inseguendo
quando mancano undici secondi
7 a 1 ma ecco vitale che vada
o dalle 12 notti nuovo faccia a
faccia volte di stata presa oggi a 8
il prossimo step to ai 250 punti andiamo
a prendere un arma wow chiaro si aspetta
attenti oltre che sotto sotto alla base
lo vedo non fu questo novero terzo visto
non dove verso le armi messo per
rendermi alle scarpe veloci ecco ti
prendi quest'arma che ti vediamo
finalmente ok a presa proprio che non
azione forse sempre solo per salire e si
è
però aspetta può tornare utile vedi se
ti metti così l'unico chi prende ne va
beh allora dovevamo miliardi e salire ma
non puoi beccare i cattivi con quella
tipo aspetto è tipo di pratica qui ti
aspetto qui sotto dove vediamo che il
prossimo cattivo sarà l'ultimo cattivo
che affronteremo vediamo chi è
ecco vitale siamo pronti ad affrontare
un ottimo cattiva con la tua arma 6
prontissimi allora arrivano in un
secondo james ed ai
quali va un attimo che ti mette
l'aspetto velocità prima c'è stato solo
scappare prima
amauri sì ma mi ha lasciato gli sta
ancora seguendo assente quando qualcun
altro camerino eccole qui provo a testa
vieni prova spararlo noi
ma mi sta portando verso di lui no cioè
che ti quelli incastonato su di lui è
milly
che cosa sta succedendo ecco un altro
vitale stato eliminato
no
l'arma lino serviva per sparare i nemici
la spagna i più vicini
allora abbiamo finito il gioco con io a
100 punti vitale 25 ma perché ha preso
l'arma ha però è sopravvissuto molte più
volte evitare quindi ha vinto vita
scrive tesi qual è stato il vostro
cattivo preferito da stato bel mi piace
allora vi lasciamo qua 4 caselli eletto
qui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video in casa su quello che preferite
buona visione
ciao